غارات على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف واداوي
انفجارات قويه في مناطق مختلفه في انحاء
البلاد
الاسبوع القادم حاكم فلوريدا سيعلن رسميا
ترشحه لخوض منافسات السباق الرئاسيه
الامريكي
مونتانا تقر تشريعا يحضر استخدام تطبيق
تيك توك لتصبح اول ولايه امريكيه تصدر هذا
القانون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم دوه انفجارات عده فجر الخميس
ومناطق اوكرانيا اخرى حيث نشدت السلطات
السكان الاحتماء في الملاجئ هناك بحسب ما
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه وقال
سيركي بوكو رئيس الاداره المدنيه
والعسكريه في كييف انه تم تسجيل سقوط حطام
في منطقه
من البيانات الخاصه بالضحايا والاضرار
هناك بدوره اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان منطقه
بوسط البلاد تتعرض لهجمات بصواريخ كروس
مشيرا الى انه اطلق تحذيرات للسكان في
سائر انحاء البلاد من خطر تعرضهم لضربات
جويه
ياتي هذا بعد ساعات قليله من اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انه تم تدمير خمس منصات
اطلاق صواريخ باتريوت يوم السادس عشر من
مايو جاري ذكرت وزاره الدفاع في بيان انه
وفقا لبيانات مؤكده وموثوقه ونتيجه للضربه
الجويه بصاروخ كينجال الفرد الصوتي تم
اصابه وتدمير محطه رادار متعدده الوظائف
للمنظومه اضافه الى خمس منصات اطلاق
صواريخ باتريوت امريكيه يذكر ان الجيش
الاوكراني يمتلك في الوقت الحالي منظومتي
زودت الولايات المتحده بواحده منها اما
ثانيه فارسلتها المانيا وهولندا تبلغ قيمه
المنظومه الواحده نحو مليار دولار
على الجانب الاخر قال مسؤول دفاع
الامريكينا نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت
عالي التقنيه المقدم لاوكرانيا تعرض
لاضرار خلاله هجوم صاروخي على كييف لكنه
لا يزال يعمل حيث اشار الى ان واشنطن تعمل
حاليا على تقييم الاضرار المحتمله التي
لحقت بنظام الدفاع الجوي رافضا الاداء
بمزيد من التفاصيل وفقا لما نشرته صحيفه
خطط فرنسا خطوه كبيره في اتجاه زياده
القدرات القتاليه للجيش الاوكراني فبعد 24
ساعه على استقباله الرئيس فلاديلنسكي اعلن
ايمانويل ماكرون بلاده ستزود اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ من جهه اخرى اعلنت المانيا
استعدادها لتسليم اوكرانيا اكبر حزمه
عسكريه منذ بدايه الحرب التفاصيل مع
الزميلين حسين قنيبل من باريس ورغد بهنا
من برلين
هنا في باريس التي زار هذا لانسكي بعد
روما وبرلين وقبل لندن كان ابرز ما قاله
ماكرون امام ضيفه ان فرنسا سترسل المزيد
من الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من
ذلك قول الرئيس الفرنسي ان مدى هذه
الصواريخ سيكون ابعد من مدى تلك التي
ارسلتها باريس سابقا الى ما سيمكن هذه
الاخيره بحسب الرئيس الفرنسي من الشروع في
شن هجومها المضاد على الجيش الروسي فرنسا
ستقوم ايضا بتاهيل طيارين عسكريين
اوكرانيين وهنا يرصد الاليزي التعليق حول
امكانيه الربط بين هذه الخطوه واحتمال
ارسال باريس يوما ما الطائرات مقاتله الى
كييف وسيرسل الفرنسيون ايضا المزيد من
المركبات المدرعه والدبابات الخفيفه
ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي تقول باريس ان هدف
تكثيف دعمها لاوكرانيا عسكريا دفاعي لا
هجومي
عندما دخلت روسيا الى اوكرانيا خرقت ميثاق
الامم المتحده الاوكرانيون يدافعون عن
انفسهم ولذلك تعطيهم فرنسا السلاح روسيا
بلد يعتدي في كل الاتجاهات لا يمكن اجراء
حوار معبوت الذي يسعى الى اجتياح الدول
المجاوره ووضعها تحت سيطرته الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ياتي في سياق دعم اوروبي واسع
النطاق تقول باريس انه قد يعدل موازين
القوى العسكري لصالح كياف هنا استقبل
المستشار الالماني قبل بضعه ايام الرئيس
الاوكراني
بحضوره عن اكبر حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
تقدمها برلين لكياف منذ بدايه الحرب بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات دولار امريكي لتصبح المانيا
بذلك ثاني اكبر مانع عسكري لاوكرانيا بعد
الولايات المتحده حزمه المساعدات
الالمانيه الجديده تضم 30 دبابه كانت
ترددت المانيا بالموافقه على تسليمها
لكياف ما تسبب بتوتر العلاقه بين الطرفين
الحزمه الضخمه الجديده تطم ايضا عشرين
ناقله جنود مدرعه من نوع اضافه الى اربعه
انظمه ايروس المتطوره المضاده للطائرات
التي قدمت الى الجانب الاوكراني هي
مساعدات للدفاع والاستعاده على الاراضي
الروسيه التي الاوكرانيه التي تم
استحلالها احتلالا من قبل الجانب الروسي
بمعنى اخر
لم يتم اعطاء او لم يتم الموافقه على
اعطاء طائرات هجوميه او صواريخ هجوميه حتى
ان تلك الانظمه الصاروخيه التي اعطيت الى
الجانب الاوكراني لا يتعدى مداها الميه
وعشرين كيلو متر اسلحه المانيه جديده يعمل
الرئيس الاوكراني ان تساعد على بدء الهجوم
المؤجل لدفع القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب
افاد مراسل العربيه بان حاكم فلوريدا روند
سانتوس يعلن ترشحه رسميا لانتخابات
الرئاسه الاسبوع المقبل كانت بدا في اولى
خطواته رسميه لاطلاق حمله الانتخابيه
الرسميه باستدعائه كبار الداعمين الى
ميامي الاسبوع القادم
ظهر رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان واصطاد عددا من جنود
القوات المسلحه امام مقر قياده القوات
البريه في الخرطوم يعد هذا احد ظهور
للبرهان منذ بدل اشتباكات مع قوات الدعم
السريع يذكر ان مبنى قياده القوات البريه
يقع بمحيط مطار الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
قبل ظهوره امس لم يظهر البرهان الى ثلاث
مرات منذ بدايه الاشتباكات وجميع ذلك في
غرف مغلقه الاول حينما ظهر اثناء عمله في
غرفه العمليات ثم تهنئه بعيد الفطر والمره
الاخيره اثناء حضوره الاجتماعاتي قيادات
عسكريه
[موسيقى]
قال مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع للشؤون
السياسيه يوسف عزت بان حميد مستعد للقاء
البرهان في اي زمان ومكان يختاره الوسطى
بشرط وقف اطلاق النار مشيرا في نفس الوقت
لان الدعم السريع سيطر على نحو 90% من
مناطق الخرطوم وبان الحرب الدائره تخللها
عمل دعائي كبير من قبل الطرف الاخر نفعزت
على هامشي لقائه برئيس جنوب السودان
الاخبار المتداوله بشان استخدام الدعم
السريع المواطنين كادروا عن بشريه
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول كبير في الامم المتحده ان خطه
المنظمه للاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان
تتطلب اثنين فاصل سته وخمسين مليار دولار
لمساعده المتضررين من الازمه هناك قال
رئيس مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه في جناب راميشا سنجام انها خمسه
وعشرين مليون شخص اي اكثر من نصف عدد
السكان في السودان يحتاجون الى المساعدات
الانسانيه والحمايه اشارت الوكاله الامميه
في الوقت ذاته لحاجاتها الى مبلغ
470 مليون دولار اضافيه لمساعده الاشخاص
الذين فروا من البلاد متوقعه ان يبلغ عدد
الفارين من السودان نحو مليون لاجئ هذا
العام مدير المكتب الاممي لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه لفت الى ان الوضع في السودان
يتحول الى مواصفه بالازمه الاقليميه
بوتيره سريعه
اعلن الامين العام المساعد لجامعه الدول
العربيه حسام زكي ان رئيس المجلس السيادي
وقائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
لن يمثل بلاد بلاده في القمه العربيه
المقرره يوم غدا في مدينه جده السعوديه
قال من سيمثل السودان في القمه مبعوث
رئاسي موفد من قبل البرهان وبحسب مصادر
دبلوماسيه فان قائد القوات المسلحه
السودانيه لن يحضر القمه كونه لا ينوي
مغادره البلاد لاسباب امنيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفصل
بسبب بطء عمليات الترميم مبنى البرلمان
البريطاني مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ترحيب كبير بعوده سوريا
الى حضنها العربي وبمشاركه دمشق في القمه
العربيه في جده الاشهادته تلتها تطلعات
لان تلعب سوريا دورا فعالا في الجامعه مثل
ما كانت من قبل
سنوات عجاف بلغ عدد اثنتي عشره سنه رفرف
خلالها العلم السوري واحدا ثم جاءت السنه
التي اغيثت فيه العلاقات السوريه العربيه
ليتوسط العلم السوري اعلام باقي الدول
المشكله للمنظمه من جديد الموعد قمه جده
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان رحب بمشاركه الوفد السوري في دوره
القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين وانتهز
هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا اليوم
ترحيب كبير من دمشق بالعوده للحضن العربي
السعوديه بدلت جهد هائل من اجل تحسين
الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه ونحن ممتنون ان
كل الدول العربيه الان موجوده في هذه
القمه المقعد لم يعد شاغرا وسوريا ابرز
الحاضرين
ترحب الجزائر اي مطرحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات الملف التركي شدد كمال
كلجدار زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري على عدم
السماح للعقليه التي سهلت دخول عشره
ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي لتركيا بالبقاء
لاداره البلاد مشيرا الى ان حزبه سيقاتل
حتى الفوز بهذه الانتخابات
اخاطب الجميع لم نجد هذا الوطن في الشارع
لن نترك وطننا للعقليه التي سمحت بدخول
عشره ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي بيننا ايها
الشباب انهضوا وتخلصوا من ذلك الياس الذي
يخيم عليكم اولئك الذين يحبون وطنهم
سياتون الى صناديق الاقتراع سنقاتل حتى
النهايه وسنفوز بالتاكيد
على جانب الاخر قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان انه واثق من ان الفوز بالجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
مشيرا في الوقت ذاته ان المعارضه التركيه
لا تمتلك رؤيه واضحه
وافقوا من الفوز بالجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وبفارق كبير كلتش دار اوغلو
تعرض لضربات كثيره اكثر مما راينا وكما
نقول دائما مشكله المعارضه بتركيا انها لا
تمتلك رؤيه او برنامجا او مشروعا لقد
غيرنا كل شيء في بلادنا لكن للاسف لم
نتمكن من تغيير المعارضه لكننا نعتقد ان
هذه الانتخابات ستؤدي الى التغيير الذي
ينتظره الجميع منذ سنوات
بالرغم من انه حاز على اقل الاصوات لانها
كفيله بان تجعل سنان اوغان المرشح القومي
عامل الحسم في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات التركيه بين اردوغان وكيلوا
قومي يميل الى المعارضه ام ذو سياسه
معاديه للاكراد قد تميل به الى اردوغان
بالرغم من الجدل في الاوساط السياسيه
والاعلاميه حول دور اصوات المرشح سنان
اوغن في حسم نتيجه الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات يطرح المرشح نفسه كالعامل الذي
سيرجح كافه الميزان في اكبر عمليه
انتخابيه في تركيا بعد ان ذهبت الى جوله
اعاده
مرشح وتحالف الاجداد الاكثر قوميه سيحسم
قراره بعد المحادثات مع المرشحين الحاليين
يمكننا القول اننا لا ندعم ايا من
المرشحين بالرغم من الميول القوميه
الا انه لا يمكن الجزم باتجاهه نحو تحالف
الطاوله السداسيه القوميه فدعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الكردي
هو الخندق الذي يفصل بين التحالف الاجداد
والطاوله السداسيه وردمه هو شرط اوغن
لتحويل اصواته الانتخابيه لمنافس اردوغان
لكن التقارب القوميه القومي قد يكبد
كلجدار اوغلو خساره الاصوات الكرديه انا
اعارض كل منظمه لا تنى بنفسها عن الارهاب
اما خلاف اوغان مع اردوغان فهو ملف
اللاجئين السوريين بينما الاول يدفع
باتجاه ترحيلهم لبلادهم باقصى سرعه يتمهل
الثاني في عمليه الترحيل بانتظار ظروف
موائمه ما قد يطيل امد الازمه
وعلى الجانب الاخر قد يضطر اردوغان للتخلي
عن اصوات حزب الدعوه الحر الكردي ليكون
الحائز على دعم اوجان هو من يتخلى عن
الورقه الكرديه الى عمر العربيه
عادت حادثه مصرع الاميره البريطانيه ديانا
الى ذاكره محبيها بعد حادث ممثل تعرض له
نجلها هاري وزوجته ميجان بعد مطارده
سيارتهما اثناء تتبع المصورين لهما في
نيويورك بحسب ما اعلن مكتب الزوجين
الامير هاري يكشف عن تعرضه وزوجته لمطارده
شبيهه بمصرع
والدتهري وميجان ووالدتها بست سيارات في
مدينه نيويورك
المطارده استمرت اكثر من ساعتين وشرفت على
التصادم اكثر من مره
الحادثه شبه كارثيه الشهره لا يجب ان تاتي
ابدا على حساب سلامه المرء
المطارده تعيد الى الذاكره مصرع الاميره
ديانا عام
1997 عندما قضت في احد انفاق باريس بعد
مطاردتها من قبل مصورين على دراجات ناريه
الخوف على
التخلي عن واجباته الملكيه عام 2020
والانتقال للعيش في كاليفورنيا
خلص تقريره لجنه برلمانيه بان البرلمان
البريطاني بحاجه ماسه الى اصلاح وترميم
والا سيواجه خطرا انهيار حقيقي بسبب بطء
عمليه الترميم دعت اللجنه بعد سنوات من
مماطله النواب الى وضع خطه واضحه التكلفه
والجدول الزمني لانجاز المهمه قبل فوات
الاوان
مبنى البرلمان هذا على ضفافه نهر التايمز
والمطل على ساعه بيجبان من المعالم
التاريخيه الشهيره في العالم وواجهه
سياحيه لملايين السياح من كل مكان لكن هذا
الصرح مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
فتقرير للجنه المحاسبه العامه بمجلس
العموم التي تدقق في مصاريف البرلمان خلص
بان خطه الترميم المبنى الواجب اعتمادها
بطيئه في التعامل مع احداث من تسرب المطر
من السقف وسقوط قطع من البناء الى الجدران
الملوث بماده المدرب بصحه العاملين بداخله
والحرائق المتفرقه هذا بشهادات مسؤولين
على الترميم وتجديد البرلمان المعروف بقصر
ويسمستر في افاداتهم امام اللجه
البرلمانيه المعنيه
امن ولكنه متداعن في مناطق رئيسيه معينه
وبحاجه ماسه الى الترميم ومن اجل الحفاظ
على سلامته على سبيل المثال من خطر نشوب
حريق كارثي يتعين علينا القيام بدوريات
عديده حيث ليس لدينا نظام قوي لمن اندلاع
الحرائق وانتشارها
لجنه المحاسبه تلوم سنوات من المماطله بعد
تحديد مجلس النواب قبل خمس سنوات لمسار
العمل الذي يكلف مليوني جنيه استرليني في
الاسبوع على مدى سبعه اعوام وخاصه النواب
الذين يرفضون الانتقال الى مباني اخرى ما
سيرفع تكلفه الترميم وصيانه المبنى الى
اكثر من 20 مليارا ويستغرق عشرات السنين
اذا استمرت الجلسه الصاخبه في البرلمان
اثناء عمليه الترميم
بريطانيا ام البرلمانات في العالم وواجهه
البلاد في الخارج بنيته التحتيه تتاكل وقد
يتعرض للتدمير قبل اصلاحه ما لم يتوقف
المسؤولون والنواب عن تجاوز المسؤوليه
بشان مخاوف التكاليف الباهضه لعمليه
الترميم في زمن التقشف مصطفى زاروا
العربيه لندن
وقع حاكم ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه تشريعا
يحضر تشغيل تطبيق مشاركه مقاطع الفيديو
القصيره لتيك توك في الولايه بحسب رؤيه
يجعل تشريع مونتانا اول ولايه تحضر
التطبيق وتمنع متاجر تطبيقات الهواتف
المحموله من توفيره داخل الولايه يذكر بان
التطبيق المملوك لشركه التكنولوجيا
الصينيه يواجه دعوات متزايده من بعض
المشرعين الامريكيين لحظره في جميع انحاء
البلاد بسبب المخاوف المتعلقه من نفوذ
الحكومه الصينيه المحتمل على المنصه
لقي تسعه اشخاص على الاقل مسرعهم في منطقه
ميليا رومانيا بالشمال ايطاليا حيث تسببت
الامطار الغزيره هناك بفيضانات غمرت احياء
واراض زراعيه باكملها ما ادى ايضا الى
اللقاء سباق فورملا واحد على حلبه ايمولا
الذي كان مقررا نهايه الاسبوع كما تسببت
الامطار الغزيره التي انهمرت على السهول
في المنطقه على مدار يومين كاملين في
فيضان نحو 20 نهرا
وفي نهايه نشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
غارات على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
في جراث قويه في مناطق مختلفه في انحاء
البلاد
الاسبوع القادم حاكم فلوريدا رونديس سيعلن
رسميا ترشحه لخوض منافسات السباق الرئاسي
الامريكي
مونتانا تقرر تشريعا يحضر استخدام تطبيق
تيك توك لتصبح اول ولايه امريكيه تصدر مثل
هذا القانون
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات